I think one there seems to be an
approach where the domestic
responsibilities are the responsibility
of the women in a home and that
handicaps a woman is because then she
has to really live two lives the second
is it is expected that women transfer
with the husbands when their husbands
are successful and move from place to
place
which again disrupts her career
particularly for organization is not
multinational or not having multiple
centers within the same country and
three it's it's a factor of the fact
that she just he is not putting that
kind of ambition naturally through
social pressures which a man is expected
to put in through social pressures
positive discrimination in favor of
women more intense training of women for
leadership positions and inducting into
the organization laterally when you have
not built it enough organically to cut
short time and three or four is to give
flexibility to women to work in more
flexible work hours including some work
from home our experience is very
positive they have a rare sense of
sensitivity they have a higher sense of
loyalty and they can be very very
successful and pointed and firm when
they need to be so our experience is
very positive
we are biasing things towards women in
terms of the population of our company
about 38% of women and we have a high
concentration of Engineers in the
company about 60% of the people in our
company are engineers so you can see
it's very unusual because the
engineering graduates of women is much
less than the male graduates of women so
we have actually bias much more in terms
of what we select from